the Joe Rogan experience you know he's
wrong about that Jeff Warner fine
the Jeff want Pacquiao fight I watched
out is that one that's when you freak
back I watched I when I first watched it
you know listening to the commentary I
was like am back yeah whooping them you
know I mean why do you why do you buddy
what I cheat him you know hmm cuz I
wanted to fight Pacquiao because I was
the next in line of course your champion
so of course I'm rooting for Peggy I
don't win because that's a bigger
fighting but after watching the fight
again I was like they not saying nothing
about autumn shots Jeff horn was hitting
Pacquiao with and he was just brutally
bullying them roughing them up they can
say all he was being dirty sometimes
your hair but but it's a fight that's
what happen you know but it was real
life mandoline Pacquiao like pushing
them all around and you see Keith
Thurman couldn't even do that yeah you
know and seeing him beat Keith Thurman
at 40 years old like god damn this guy's
great
I mean just look at his career with
eight different weight classes world
fighting 88 different weight classes 40
years old
beats Keith Thurman who's in his prime
right crazy I mean what a man man what a
world champion only a short time back
the hands of time on that one it's
[ __ ] crazy ending any foreign spurts
both almost fought in spurts and I
thought keith was gonna pick up on it
but Pacquiao was only fighting fighting
they ended around like Keith would come
on a strong at the beginning of the
round and it would be like alright Keith
winning winning this round man packages
for like it's right I'll pop up and then
Keith would be like i neva seen the flow
when he dropped him with that right hook
early in the first you like oh right
[ __ ] ya know I was like he jumped in
with the Laughing in followed by like I
was straight right it's crazy yeah it
was crazy it's like wow the shoulder yep
that's his plans yeah they were showing
him hitting other fighters with it the
same thing well boom he has such a
unique style the leaping in dude if he
came in what
on you but I give I'd take my hat off to
pack y'all like do you think it's
possible that you could get a crack at
him now cuz now there he's you know he's
in the hunt right now I bet I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say so because I was in
dimensions and talk to fight Pacquiao
since 2014 and we was in the same
promotional company and they couldn't
make it happen so you think it's because
he's not interested in that I don't
think he was interested in it because
his coach mentioned numerous of times he
didn't want him to fight me hmm
he wanted him to stay away from me so I
don't think it was interesting yeah well
I could see that at this stage of his
career but you know Keith Thurman is a
[ __ ] murderous puncher right which
was one of the reasons why it's more
impressive that he beat him and so who
are they talking about Pacquiao matching
up with next he chasing him a way there
so why not right Boyd come on I know you
love money he was saying that he thinks
Floyd's out of money already because he
says Floyd spend so much money he's
probably already out of it well he's
paying money too I think he's out spam
where money and employ anybody yo oh
that's right cuz he's got like 50 people
that he just like you had supported yeah
I mean he's a he's an interesting guy
man cuz he's so friendly like you know
like Pat even like when people are trash
talking he's like smiling and then the
kids in that ring later like this is a
whole different set of rules he's flying
with like you know keep their been
talking about you gonna crucify them
don't say that good luck in the fight
like he's a killer pool players know
that about Pacquiao no it's like world
class like he could play pool
professionally me tune really yeah you
could play oh we got applying that yeah
I heard you guys know personalist I'm
pretty good yeah you good okay what do
you play whatever you want to play you